what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here is John here Humphrey we're gonna
watch the trailer today for Keanu Reeves
new film called man the it's just called
replicas just called replicas replicants
at the Van Damme movie called replicas
actually yeah you fight some another
movie fought its way
since cardiac death 7 hours 15 minutes
Thomas Middleditch Wow
[Music]
my wife's that's for the Nexus oh you
have kids love your wife
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
there was a crash oh she's dead Oh
[Music]
something already has
[Music]
no he's gone bad I've seen a lot of this
movie out
well Sonny Sonny
[Music]
I didn't defy every natural water is
just to lose you again
dark cloning movie
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah miss clone movies totes mass my
favorite genres what kind of clone but a
whoa interesting yeah yeah yeah I'm kind
of half and half half I'm like good half
this could be cool this could also be
like rememory yeah you're like kind of
cool trailer but I've heard this isn't
very good at all I get your idea but
someone has gone off to deepen with the
idea the idea of a cloning gone wrong
you know or just you know guy gone
desperate and using cloning for yeah
every that's been done plenty of times I
guess what looks different about it is
it seems like it's just a much darker
more a little more grounded in its
storytelling yeah at the same time
though it does look a little bit like it
could be very cliche yeah especially
with Thomas Middleditch Hillel disre
Middleditch and Thomas Middleditch
something could go horribly wrong I'm
like yeah we I mean that's what I like
about it because often times the
scientist guy who creates the clone is
not the main character the main
character is usually someone else and he
comes across a scientist who's kind of
messed up this guy it seems like it's a
very personal tale about the guy who's
doing the illegal cloning process
Jonah Reeves I think and pretty much
relate to something like the plays a lot
of characters who lose something but he
did lose many years ago he had a very
terrible tragedy to happen to him where
he lost a wife and baby in a car
accident and I'm like this is pretty
close to home yeah it's gotta be
cathartic in some way for him yeah
exactly
I guess that's partially why I'm drawn
to it to you guys more family men lately
you know as a wife in John wick and then
we saw knock-knock where he's a family
man and there
and I'm like is even a family man right
now in real life whereas he just really
drawn to these types of characters he's
just got a bunch of different on-screen
families yeah well we're gonna say what
I thought was interesting was Thomas
Middleditch I wasn't distracted going
funny guys I feel like I can believe him
in this it seems like a good
transitional role for him I think that's
why I like it because it's still look
nerdy dude who's you know do with what
he's working on is super intense and you
know off the books and all these things
we're seeing him deal with intense
situations on shows yeah it's like if
you just change the music and a couple
of the kinds of scenes you chose to show
us I can see this guy last silicon
valley's isn't going kind of dark I'm
just like yeah I could see he's a smart
lab guy what I'm hoping this movie does
especially with Alice Eve being the wife
I think where I feel like it can go
wrong is getting caught up in the
thriller part of it with the plot of you
holding yeah coming in no I gotta keep
them alive where I found it fascinating
was the earlier parts where his wife and
children don't realize that are clones I
feel like if they can focus on that
personal entanglement that relationship
the personal stuff in the ethics you
yeah that will make this movie
interesting give me a good sci-fi movie
that causes good thought-provoking
debates and whatnot instead of what the
last half became which is you know like
yeah especially with the cloning
territory I mean it's probably cool I
heard I heard I had a pretty bomb panel
that's all I heard was like great panel
I never mind I'm like I know this was
about autos they had a great panel and
my CC if you got a great palate that's
what they say you know one great panel
can can change the word all right guys
well what do you think of the replicas
trailer are you a positive about it did
you see knock-knock think 10 other
people did we did oh yeah know eight
other people did you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell followed a chart Humphrey on twit
and in
and you could check out our patreon
become a patronage act I die
take care do it